somebody is overcome with a sensation of
nausea and they vomit during their fast
does this nullify the fast is this
something can they resume their fast
after the vomit has come out vomiting
can either be intentionally or it can be
unintentionally and I beloved Prophet
Mall said it's mentioned in it's
mentioned
in in the book of fasting Hadith number
720 I beloved Prophet said that a person
who vomits
unintentionally he should complete his
fast and the fast is not broken but the
person who vomits intentionally the
person who vomits intentionally
deliberately then the fast is broken and
he has to make up for the fast
afterwards and the same Hadith is
repeated in Abu da volume number two in
the book of fasting Hadith number
2374 where the Beloved Prophet M wasam
said that anyone who warit suddenly same
unintentionally then he does not have to
atone for it but if someone vomits
intentionally deliberately he has to
atone for it but the person who does it
deliberately for example by sticking a
finger in the throat or by pressing the
stomach or deliberately smelling
something which is nasty or looking at
food which will make him vmit and he
continues that then it comes under the
category deliberately done so then his
fast is broken he has to make up for
that but if it comes unintentionally no
problem but when the vomit comes he
should not swallow the vomit after it
has reach the mouth if he swalls the
vomit after it reaches the mouth it will
nfy the fast so when a vomit comes you
should see that the vomitus comes out
and if it's unintentional it will not
break his fast thanks for that that's um
very comprehensive Dr